bonjour bonsoir le 11 septembre 2001 le
world trade center
cette formidable déflagration qui qui va
toucher le monde entier qui est en fait
évidemment la mort de 3000 personnes
une atteinte au monde au monde libre
mais aussi la déflagration de deux
mythes le mythe d'icare et le mythe de
babel cet événement important mavs et
m'inspirer à l'époque un certain nombre
de réflexions et je me suis inspiré de
2,2 deux auteurs donc que je vais que je
vais vous citer stoxx à ausone qui était
un maître un chef d'orchestre allemand
et qui avait dit ceci le 11 septembre
c'est le plus grand spectacle plus
grandes oeuvres d'art qu'on ait jamais
produit au monde
bon bien entendu c'était assez
offusquant par rapport aux 3000
personnes qui étaient mortes mais ce que
ce que j'ai retenu est ce que je veux
passer comme message c'est de dire que
là il y avait encore des mots et ai
encore des mots pour expliquer
l'impensable et que peut être un jour on
aura plus les mots pour expliquer ce qui
peut arriver
et puis vous avez jean baudrillard qui
avait dit ceci cet événement est la mère
et la mère de tous les événements ce à
partir desquels on commence à repenser
donc là aussi c'était c'était
extrêmement important ça veut dire que
c'est pas la fin il faut réfléchir et je
me suis mis moi personnellement aussi à
réfléchir à ce sujet et je vous propose
deux façons de l'aborder
la première je les fais avec deux
penseurs le premier c'est carl von
clausewitz qui est un penseur militaire
qui de l'auteur de la guerre est le
prolongement de la politique par
d'autres moyens
et puis rené girard rené girard qui est
un anthropologue et philosophe français
et qui a défini
le concept du mythique de la défense
delà de la violence
le mimétisme de la violence et pour
faire court c'est le fait que la
violence dans l'humanité se reproduit et
génère toujours une violence et pour
l'instant on n'a pas arrêté
ce type de violence voilà et je vais
essayer à travers ce que j'ai vécu
vous essayez de vous démontrer ce
mimétisme de la violence alors le
deuxième élément donc de cette
démonstration c'est un peu ma carrière
en fait les défis et que je vais vous
séquencé en quatre temps et qui
répondent beaucoup plus à des périodes
finalement historique plus qu'à des
périodes personnelle ou familiale
c'est c'est peut-être le lot des
militaires justement peut-être aussi de
certains fonctionnaires de de
s'accrocher plutôt à des périodes
politiques plutôt qu'à des périodes
familiale
alors là la première période est une
période disons classique c'est la
période où personnellement j'ai voulu
être officiers je voulais être officiers
parce que je dis classique parce que
j'ai été très influencé à l'époque par
la lecture de lyautey le maréchal
lyautey c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé ce
ça aide
lyautey maréchal lyautey lyautey nous
vous pouvez nous enseigne et ceci à
savoir que d'abord il avait fait le rôle
social de l'officier donc l'officier cas
inverse rôle dans la société
j'avais été extrêmement impressionnés
par le fait que lorsqu'il était à
madagascar et qu'il avait vaincu un chef
rebelle
il avait invité ce chef rebelle à la
table à sa table le soir donc il avait
qu'a fait un peu la violence il avait
rétabli le chef dans dans toute son aura
et il avait pu faire beaucoup de travail
à madagascar moi je trouvais ça le tout
à fait étonnant et puis quelque chose
d'aussi qui m'avait impressionné que je
vous livre et qu'on se souvient pas mais
lorsqu'il avait appris le la guerre le
déclenchement de la guerre de 14 il
avait dit c'est une guerre civile
voilà des choses qui m'avait
impressionné qui ont fait que j'ai voulu
moi être aussi officier donc je suis
rentrée à saint cyr cette école qui est
connu et à une époque que je dis
classique d'une violence classique parce
que c'est vrai qu'après et je veux que
vous en parler j'ai connu une violence
extrême
j'ai côtoyé une violence extrême là
c'est une violence classique c'est celle
qui a été motivée pour moi par le
maréchal lyautey c'est le sel de la
conscription le temps du service
militaire
c'est le temps des gros bataillons c'est
le temps des des occupations la fin de
l'ère coloniale
mais cette période est terminée et on va
on passe donc une autre période qu'est
la période dite nucléaire de la pierre
fort de la guerre froide
en sortant de saint cyr 1966 jeu j'ai le
choix ou bien justement de ce que je
vous dis la conscription les gros
bataillons ou bien le le la guerre
froide le nucléaire et je choisis pour
être au front de quelque part je choisis
donc de servir une arme nucléaire
voilà la première violence donc je
voulais vous parler et je sers cette
arme qui est derrière moi et cuts d'une
arme américaine dit sonné john faut
savoir qu'elle elle tirait à 40
kilomètres je pouvais avoir une bombe de
40 kilos tonnes de fois hiroshima et il
y avait globalement en allemagne j'étais
à wingen pas très loin d'ici
il y avait globalement 300 rentrer comme
celle ci alors ce qui est intéressant
est ce qui est important pour moi c'est
que que ce que je voulais ce qui est
important aujourd'hui la réflexion qui
est importante c'est de savoir que
lorsque un un tir était décidée en
manoeuvre nous avions une séquence de
sept heures et personnellement moi
j'avais une heure la dernière heure du
tir
j'avais aimé mais je ne vais plus que
une heure avant le tir lui même c'est à
dire je chargeais la roquette je sais
mais telle la bombe à l'intérieur de la
roquette
voilà j'avais tout s'est tu estimes duré
une heure et j'avais posé la question à
l'époque de savoir et je n'étais pas le
seul à poser si je perds le contact avec
mon chef
une heure avant le tir que fait elle et
bien la réponse est assez
au delà du possible c'était vous tirer
quand même donc je répète une heure
avant le tir dans les années 70 nous
nous devions tirer même si nous n'avions
plus la liaison avec
avec le chef s'il ce qui veut dire que
si un jour j'avais été chargé dans une
crise et que j'avais eue cet ordre de
tir
je dis pas que je ne dis pas que je leur
ai fait je ne sais pas mais peut-être
que d'autres leur effet est dû
enclencher un tir et un tir qui aurait
évidemment déclenché des tirs de
représailles puisque de l'autre côté il
y avait probablement au minimum le même
nombre de rampe est peut-être le double
imaginez-vous donc la région deuxième
élément c'est cette violence nucléaire
m'a fait réfléchir et je vous cite
quelqu'un que j'ai lu et qui est très
intéressant qui s'appelle jean pierre
dupuy qui est un polytechnicien qui
enseigne à stanford et qui a étudié le
nucléaire qui a étudié la guerre froide
et dans la guerre froide
il a relevé pendant toute l'histoire de
la guerre froide
il a relevé 10 certes alerte alerte
nucléaire et il a été il a été interrogé
les jambes
les généraux qui avaient été les
responsables à ce moment là et il y aura
posé la question de savoir pourquoi
pourquoi il n'y avait pas eu t il la
réponse est je vous la livre est
terrifiante et coup de bol et enfin je
vais vous parler de petrov parce que le
titre de ce ca etc
stanislas petrov et ça c'est très
important le 23 24 septembre 1983 le
document colonel stanislas petrov et
dans le bunker soviétique et sur les
écrans apparaissent une
une alerte de fusée américaine qui
arrive une deuxième alerte une troisième
une quatrième une cinquième il y a cinq
minutes cinq minutes entre le moment où
ils voient les alertes américaine et
l'arrivée sur le territoire soviétique
il a cinq minutes en cinq minutes le
lelas l'urss peut être atteinte
et là ça a été le moment le plus
important de sa vie et il prend et il
prend la décision de ne pas alerter son
commandement
ils y croient pas et je pense que ce
colonel a sauvé la planète parce qu'il
faut imaginer cinq fusées arrivant ce
l'urss l'urss en envoie autant de
l'autre côté et lui même dit interrogé
après il dira probablement il y aurait
eu un échange de centaines de fusées
nucléaire c'est l'homme du 20e siècle
stanislas petrov c'étaient les
soviétiques ont mis beaucoup de temps à
délivrer son nom je passe sam
à part la période terroriste puisque
justement j'ai connu de violence ça tout
à fait extraordinaire une violence la
violence nucléaire et la violence du
terrorisme puisque je fais partie de
cette cellule antiterroriste et bon j'ai
eu quelques quelques je me suis beaucoup
occupé du liban à l'époque et à travers
les otages qu'ils avaient été pris à
l'époque et j'ai eu de quelques
informations à fort assez intéressante à
vous communiquer et des choses si vous
voulez qu'ils font que retrouve ces
éléments aujourd'hui à savoir par
exemple
le j'ai rencontré le chef des pasdarans
à l'époque qui était un homme terrible
et kirghiz qui terrifiait les syriens et
quand je vais rencontrer rafik douce les
syriens avaient enlevé toute image de la
pièce où j'ai rencontré et il était
terrifié
donc c'était l'allier le lien avec
l'iran j'ai fait un voyage de damas à
beyrouth avec un preneur d'otages est ce
que les syriens qui m'avait donnée qui
ne rêvait que d'une chose arriver à
beyrouth et pouvoir tuer donc voilà
l'image de de ce terroriste qui ne rêve
que d'une chose c'est de tuer g j'ai
entendu des chants à l'intérieur de
dents dans une salle où il y avait douze
été reçu par un ministre de ministre la
défense syrien et j'entendais des
centimes étaient traduits par un un
poète syrien
ces 110 m l'espagne fiancée de l'islam
donc tous les ingrédients de que j'ai
connu dans les années 80 90 on les
retrouve aujourd'hui
donc je les appelais le mimétisme de la
violence parce que tout est fait pour
quelque part nous rendent cette violence
donc ils nous accusent de les avoir de
leurs avoirs je paie alors ça je passe
tout de suite je passe sur coup achi
puisque c'est le dernier élément
terroriste extrêmement important c'est
un dessin qui a été fait par mon fils
pour vous dire que deux on est enfin
dans la famille même nous sommes très
impliqués et qu'il avait il avait donné
ce dessin à lupstein potes et qui a été
il a été sélectionné parmi les les 40
meilleurs dessins au monde sur charlie
alors charlie est intéressant parce que
d'abord c'est aussi une vengeance une
vengeance par rapport au mal à mahomet
par rapport aux prophètes
c'est aussi un élément important il faut
absolument oublier l'histoire du loup
solitaire et il faut se dire que on est
dans le système deux ennemis proches
l'ennemi proches il est fait pour
stigmatiser toute une population en
france notamment l'islam est l'ennemi
proches il est il est aussi fait du côté
de al qaïda ou de dèche pour éliminer
tous les musulmans et d'autres religions
de façon à pouvoir un moment donné
opposés et jeter l'un contre l'autre des
populations et c'est le phénomène
évidemment de dice aujourd'hui lucky et
qui a pris un territoire et qui veut
s'opposer à l'occident
globalement
alors je dirais qu on est dans le
phénomène dans un phénomène de
d'opposition de masse plutôt qu'un que à
une guerre de civilisation un peu comme
à la hutington masse des des frustrés et
contre la masse des possédants et
justement dans le cadre du mimétisme de
la violence je dirais que le terrorisme
globalement est en fait le la revanche
de la violence ce nucléaire que nous
avec eux donc j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
alors est-ce que c'est inéluctable
donc ce n'est pas inéluctable puisque je
vous ai parlé de petrov
petrov un moment donné il a il a réussi
à arrêter ce qui devait être peut être
la fin du monde ou le un cataclysme
donc ça c'est quelque chose à prendre en
compte
et deuxièmement rené girard aussi rené
girard nous apprend que il ya peut-être
des solutions et il en parle
rené g et reparle à travers salomon
quand il dit danser dans ses ouvrages il
parle de seulement il dit salomon
lorsque il propose aux deux femmes de
deux coups père l'enfant de ces la femme
la lame avant qui propose de le donner
son enfant à la peau si ps il dit c'est
elle qui brisa violence et même il dit
c'est elle qui repose en dieu
et autres les membres de claire et
mandela qui vaut 6 abandonné ont brisé
la violence et j'ai une troisième alors
qu'il serait plutôt une quatrième une
quatrième phase je connais assez
fréquenté beaucoup de d'africains je
suis passé un réseau plutôt moyen
orientales un réseau africain et j'ai
trouvé qu'il y avait une ressource du
côté d'afrique une ressource importante
et que peut-être ils étaient eux en
mesure de régler des problèmes que nous
occidentaux n'avons pas pu régler
notamment par rapport à l'islam et je
crois que d'abord je crois que l'avenir
de l'europe
l'avenir de l'europe est en afrique même
par rapport à ces problèmes de fond
frasor de fondamentalisme est une des
preuves c'est le prix nobel est accordé
à la tunisie et qui nous apporte quelque
chose et c'est aussi ces deux phrases de
léopold senghor qui était le président
du sénégal pendant 20 ans alors qu'il
était catholique sur 95 % de musulmans
et qui a dit ceci
l'europe c'est la raison hellène et
l'afrique c'est l'émotion c'est pour ça
que je dis notre avenir de l'europe par
rapport à tous nos problèmes et
peut-être mavericks
merci